bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte on
dit souvent que ce qu'on ne sait pas ne
fait pas mal mais dans l'histoire qui
nous intéresse c'est tout le contraire
il existe une maladie très répandue dans
les troupeaux laitiers en amérique du
nord
longtemps on a cru qu'elle n'avait pas
vraiment d'impact mais aujourd'hui on se
rend compte qu'elle mine la santé des
vaches et celle des entreprises
[Musique]
qui aurait dit qu'un jour une simple
goutte de lait révèlerait l'état de
santé d'une vache au delà de ses
qualités nutritives le lait renferme une
foule d'informations c'est d'ailleurs
l'analyse de ce liquide qui a permis de
découvrir que presque tous les troupeaux
laitiers au québec sont touchés par une
maladie inconnue du public
nous sommes à la ferme vigilants à
coteau du lac en montérégie
[Musique]
dans ce réservoir se trouve le nez de
toutes les vaches en lactation de la
ferme
[Musique]
tous les deux jours
le camion de lait vient faire sa
cueillette à chaque collecte
on mesure entre autres la teneur en
matières grasses et en protéines du lait
mais en 2018 on y détecte des anticorps
produits en réaction à une maladie pour
laquelle il n'existe aucun vaccin ni
aucun traitement
la leucose bovines laitières sont
étanches et sur l'extrême et des
producteurs de lait qu'on est allés l'y
consulte xt la con et vous la prévalence
du troupeau on en avait entre 5 et 25
pour ça on en reste un peu sauf prier
sur le coup on était ambiguë
aucun signe extérieur n'aurait pu
permettre à la jeune productrice de
deviner que son petit troupeau d'une
trentaine de bêtes comptait des vaches
atteinte de la leucose bovine ce qui
n'est pas étonnant
c'est une maladie relativement est
sixième le virus au stockage au niveau
des cellules sanguines puisqu'on va voir
le plus souvent c'est finalement une
diminution graduelle la résistance des
animaux de sorte que les animaux vont
souvent à graphiquement fait des
pneumonies ou des maladies très rennes
usuels puis vont malheureusement quittés
trop tôt pour ces raisons là donc c'est
difficile pour un producteur souvent de
s'apercevoir qui est aux prises avec
cette maladie
[Musique]
la leucose bovine peut se manifester
sous la forme d'un cancer et entraîne le
développement de tumeurs
mais comme le roulement dans les fermes
laitières est élevé seulement 5% des
vaches atteindront un âge assez avancé
que ces tumeurs apparaissent
le système immunitaire étant attaqué la
vache vie moins longtemps et produit
moins de lait il y avait des scènes
canadiennes qui avaient tf1 l'ontario
qui disait qu'en moyenne les vaches
possible la leucose reste dans les
troupeaux une lactation loin on talla
sylla ouvertes sont négatifs de cette
lactation dos et de l'argent
longtemps la méthode préconisée pour
diagnostiquer la leucose bovine était
d'analyser le sens de chaque vache
une procédure qui demande l'intervention
d'un vétérinaire et qui peut s'avérer
coûteuse pour l'ensemble d'un troupeau
mais aujourd'hui pour le même prix
qu'une seule analyse sanguine
une autre méthode permet de connaître la
prévalence de la maladie dans un
troupeau
le test de réservoir pour savoir à quel
point la leucose bovine est répandue
les producteurs de lait du québec lance
en 2017 une campagne sans précédent au
canada
des échantillons sont prélevés dans les
réservoirs de toutes les fermes
laitières de la province
ils sont envoyés ici au laboratoire de
la can est un centre d'expertisé en
production laitière
ces échantillons permettent de savoir
selon la quantité d'anticorps présent
dans le lait si un troupeau est
faiblement moyennement ou fortement
contaminé une avancée majeure
prenez trop paul de 100 verges par
exemple mais au lieu de pester
individuellement les 100 vaches mais on
fait un ter sur le réservoir qui pour un
centième du prix russell thèse mais j'ai
déjà une idée de ce qui sera augmentée
les analyses effectuées sur l'ensemble
du territoire québécois révèle que 90 %
des troupeaux sont infectés à différents
degrés une situation semblable au reste
du canada et aux états unis les
producteurs découvre également que la
maladie leur fait perdre de l'argent
au québec la majorité des troupeaux sont
moyennement contaminée pour une ferme de
60 vaches cela représente des pertes
pouvant atteindre plus de 13 mille
dollars par année pour une ferme de plus
de 100 vaches les pertes peuvent grimper
à 22 milles dollars par année
même les petites fermes peut contaminer
ne sont pas épargnés dans mon sens qu'à
25% me disait que j'avais une perte
entre 9,5 à plus 500 par année pour mon
troupeau avec c'est sûr que ça m'allume
et muller pour peu que bon il y avait
vraiment un enjeu réel sur la maladie
pour savoir quel vaches sont atteintes
émilie therrien effectué des analyses
individuelles celle ci révèle que le
troupeau compte trois vaches malades
aujourd'hui meilleur est de fixer ces
deux là qu'on examine à sam
ça nous permet de tourner et ophélie
khalfi elles sont plus en retrait des
autres pots les derniers tests de
contamination dans une minorité de cas
le virus peut se transmettre de la mère
au foetus pendant la gestation
mais la principale voie de contamination
c'est le sens une infime quantité suffit
pour infecter une bête
il ya 10 à 15 ans il ya vingt ans au
piquet les ennemis souvent avec la même
aiguille on pouvait piquer 5 animal
différent dans ce que je dis c'est sûr
si aucun ajacciens fait un animal bien
en géant j'ai déduit change
d'aiguillettes les ennemis je passe
c'est même pas une goutte de 5 peut
infecter l'autre animal la firme de la
fortune est situé à st roch de l'achigan
c'est une véritable histoire de famille
autrefois propriété du grand père elle
est aujourd'hui passée aux mains de ses
enfants et petits enfants dans le
paysage québécois
c'est une grande exploitation 290 vaches
et près de 900 hectares de terres en
culture au fil des ans malgré que ces
vaches soit issu d'une excellente
génétique jacques la fortune en perd
quelques unes des vaches plus âgés
victimes de la leucose mais en 2008 il
est troublé par la mort d'une jeune beur
l'achat de quelque chose mais quand tu
perds ton temps que quand même des coups
à son premier vous d'après tapas et de
foot a prédit à la main je savoure est
certaine le testing propose la même
année toutes les vaches subissent un
test de lugos bovine
quarante cinq bêtes sont déclarées
positives ce qui représentait alors 27%
du troupeau
rapidement un plan précis et élaboré
pour éviter d'autres contaminations
il faut aller vers ce qui était possible
on les mettait en dernière au bout de
ranger ses vaches le et est réparé
dernier et c'est sûr que quand que tout
faire quand un jet küng acheter faute
chant d'aiguilhe à toutes les vaches ce
que ce soit 1,1 six nations une fouille
d'un ananas et tout a changé ces gars
les méthodes des carnages aussi il faut
toujours faire attention au sort une
foule de petits détails mais qui feront
toute la différence
certaines vaches malades mais toujours
productives sont vendus les plus
vieilles prennent le chemin de
l'abattoir
cinq ans plus tard en 2013 le troupeau
est exempt de la maladie et il est
encore aujourd'hui un cas extrêmement
rare car au fil des ans la prévalence de
la leucose bovine a emprunté une
trajectoire inquiétante au début des
années 1980 environ 36% des troupeaux
laitiers québécois étaient positifs en
2002 la proportion avait bondi à 74 %
pour atteindre 90% en 2018
pourtant plusieurs pays européens tout
comme l'australie ont réussi à se
débarrasser de cette maladie en france
depuis 1988 les vaches contaminés sont
systématiquement éliminés
cette mesure a entraîné l'abattage de
cent mille vaches
au départ c'est la crainte d'un lien
avec la santé humaine qui a poussé les
autorités de plusieurs pays européens à
réagir à l'époque certains chercheurs
avaient émis
la possibilité d'un lien entre cette
maladie bovine de la ligue aux bobines
et à l'époque la leucémie chez les
humains donc c'est ce qui avait mis les
européens peu un en action puis
finalement des années un terrien s'est
aperçu qu'il n'y avait aucun lien entre
les deux maladies depuis d'autres
chercheurs ont établi des liens avec
certains types de cancer
particulièrement le cancer du sein
pourtant les taux de ces cancers sont
moins élevés en amérique du nord où la
maladie est présente qu'en europe de
l'ouest où elle a été éradiquée mais
comme les gènes de ce virus ont été
détectés dans des tissus humains il vaut
mieux être prudent
chaque maladie animale comme industrie
on se pose toujours la question d'un
lien possible avec la santé humaine dans
le canal e cause c'est très clair que la
pasteurisation du lait est inactive
complètement le virus et c'est très plat
que la cuisson de la viande aussi
détruit complètement le virus n'avait
pas besoin des pommes malade il ya un
enjeu de santé publique
par contre en tant qu'industrie on veut
vraiment 18 au maximum la prévalence de
cette maladie aux six un jour
des gens trouver un lien potentiel mais
on aura fait le travail puis on aura
finalement minimiser le risque au
maximum mieux gérer les seringue et
l'hygiène générale à la ferme ne peut
qu'être bénéfique puisque on peut
contrôler et du même coup d'autres
maladies transmises par le sang autant
de gestes qui contribuent à la bonne
santé des vaches et à celle des
entreprises
nous on a fait la preuve ici il ya moyen
de s'en débarrasser à 100 prochains 105
il ya des pertes financières immédiates
un épaules du producteur ou ça demande
un investissement ou des investissements
sur une perte financière pour moi c'est
du long terme
c'est le plus beau cadeau qu'on peut
faire la génération qui va nous suivre
c'est de laisser un troupeau exemple de
toute maladie entrepôts 5 g en asie
les producteurs de lait du québec
procéderont d'ici un an à une autre
campagne pour analyser le lait de toutes
les fermes de la province ils pourront
ainsi savoir si les mesures mises en
place permettent de diminuer la
prévalence de la maladie